I wasn't gonna bring any guests out
today but my friend Justin Bieber people
[Music]
[Applause]
ariana grande delivered a major
headlining set Sunday night with a
little help from Justin Bieber
[Applause]
but before Justin took the stage re
kicked things off with raindrops an
angel cried off her sweetener album
[Applause]
then it was all about God is a woman the
25 year old rocked out to a few hits off
her latest album thank you next
including bad idea and break up with
your girlfriend I'm bored
[Music]
but when Ari welcomed her buddy Justin
to the stage they brought the house down
[Music]
Justin said that the performance marked
his first time on stage in two years I
came out here I had no idea was going to
be on this stage absolutely
I wore this right outfit not knowing
that I was going to be onstage so
anyways if I first time onstage in like
two years
[Applause]
wait what I'll come soon you heard that
right
Justin who sings with Ariana on lil
Dickies new single earth promised new
music is on its way
[Music]
Ariana closed out her show with no tears
left to cry
[Music]
and came back to the stage for her
encore performance
[Music]
you
[Music]